War Thunder is an online vehicle-based
MMO and it's free to play but could
playing War Thunder have other
consequences a recent thread on the
game's subreddit claims that the US
government is asking prospective hires
at Arms manufacturers whether or not
they play War Thunder yeah it seems too
crazy to be true right there's no way
it's actually real
right
foreign
Sable round might be a closely guarded
state secret but it's no secret that
subscribing to the channel liking the
video and ringing that notification Bell
are great ways to help support our
channel so War Thunder is a game that
just can't stay out of the News That's
because the users for this game are so
dedicated that when they want to see a
balance change they bring receipts most
recently this took the form of a leak
involving the actual real life F-16
multi-role fighter aircraft and aim 120
air-to-air missile we're talking
technical details of both real-life
military systems leaked in a public
forum by users but first let's just
briefly explain the game War Thunder is
an online vehicle-based game where
you're able to play as vehicles from
basically a whole Century of history and
there's a battle tier which sort of
limits the top level of vehicles that
could be in any one match like if you
want to you can fly a biplane against a
jet fighter but only if you enter a game
where you know there will be Jets based
on the battle tier and you choose to buy
a plane I did play the game a long time
ago and it was pretty fun but I quit
like just after they added tanks I think
my favorite thing was flying some of the
weirder aircraft that they put in the
game but here's the kicker there aren't
other games like War Thunder like not
really so the fans here can't just like
pack up and go to a competitor because
there really aren't other games that are
exactly like War Thunder it's pretty
singular honestly but what that means is
that War Thunder fans are dedicated to
improving their game whatever that takes
that F-16 leak I mentioned happened
about a week ago and they posted some
technical manuals that frankly they
shouldn't have were they strictly
speaking classified no but this happens
so often now that Gaijin entertainment
the game's developer pretty much just
has to remove these things unless they
have clear proof that this information
is publicly available and so in the case
of these specific documents they are
apparently still restricted and
additionally labeled export controlled
and DOD only as well as distribution
authorized to US government agencies
only yeah I mean I I don't think that
the War Thunder forums qualify as a U.S
government agency but this is just the
most recent time I'm going to quickly
blow through the other incidents for you
right now a few days after the F-16 aim
120 incident I mentioned earlier someone
posted over a dozen weapon system
manuals for the f-15e Strike Eagle
fighter aircraft in July 2021 a user
leaked information about the UK's
Challenger two main battle tank and the
ministry of Defense confirmed to Gaijin
that the documents were not supposed to
be public in October 2021 a former
member of the French military shared
documents that showed the turret
rotation speed of the Leclerc main
battle tank as modeled in the game was
not accurate in June 2022 someone leaked
technical specifications for a Chinese
armor-piercing Sable round the DTC 10
125 millimeter APF SDS the this was
information that was classified in China
and the system itself is actually pretty
interesting I have seen evidence that
there are other leaks that I haven't
been able to confirm like one involving
the Eurocopter tiger helicopter but I'm
willing to believe that it happened
because well it just keeps happening so
two questions first off how dangerous is
this behavior of course the country in
question the level of classification
these all come into play but in the case
of the Challenger two main battle tank
that I mentioned earlier the UK's
Ministry of Defense confirmed yeah these
aren't supposed to be public and that
under the official Secrets act there
would be potentially a 14-year sentence
for making them public secondly who are
these leakers who are just posting
sensitive military documents to a video
games public forum well in some cases it
seems as their former military personnel
who actually work on these Platforms in
some way but at the end of the day
they're posting on a forum where they're
using a pseudonym I'm sure if the
developer really wanted to find out your
name and you gave it to them they can
and they might even provide that to a
law enforcement agency if they are asked
to do so it doesn't feel like this is
some kind of coordinated effort by a
small group instead it's people who
really just like War Thunder and will do
anything to get the balance changes they
want at the same time it seems like some
of these people thought that the
documents they were posting were
Declassified and in some cases like I
said they were actually Declassified but
Gaijin does have to remove these things
without evidence that they are okay to
publicly post and in some cases just
because they're Declassified like I said
doesn't mean they don't have some other
kind of restriction on their publication
it's classified isn't the only thing
that people put on documents to be like
don't publish this and all of this is
despite the fact that the developer says
that the vehicles in the game are based
on publicly available information which
means that even if you figure out that
the muzzle velocity of a type 99 9 is
wrong they're not going to use
classified information to make that
change but as I mentioned at the
beginning of the video could playing War
Thunder affect your job prospects well a
recent thread on the game's subreddit
makes exactly that claim a Reddit user
claimed that an investigator contacted
them to complete a background check for
their friend who was applying to
Raytheon on arms manufacturer they said
that the investigator asked them whether
their friend played War Thunder I was
suspicious though beyond the general
concept which does seem pretty wild they
named Raytheon as the company and
Raytheon currently produces the aim 120
missile which was part of that F-16
League that I talked about so if I was
going to like make something up I
probably would have picked Raytheon so I
reached out to Raytheon for confirmation
and I got a hold of Chris Johnson the
senior director of global media
relations at the company he told me
after checking in with some other people
that quote as I expected we only look at
a person's education employment and
criminal history when hiring we've never
looked into a person's video game habits
that being said if the person needed a
security clearance from a U.S government
agency the government agency itself
would conduct a background check that's
not something we have any insight into
and we wouldn't know what types of
questions they asked still a question
about video games seems pretty unlikely
hope that helps while it's great to hear
that Raytheon doesn't care if you play
War Thunder the response meant that it
was theoretically possible that a US
government agency would ask about it so
I did the only reasonable thing that
someone in my position would do and I
sent an email to the Pentagon but in the
end it was all a waste of time well I
got to tell my co-workers I was asking
the Pentagon about a video game so that
was pretty cool but yeah it didn't pan
out because when I logged on to write
about this thing the guy had already
admitted that the post was fake and
honestly I wasn't that surprised I don't
know exactly how how many people play
War Thunder now but if you're asking me
there are probably a lot bigger risk
factors for divulging State Secrets than
playing this video game you know stuff
like having huge personal debts posting
on Facebook about how the revolution is
coming and you can't stop the storm and
you know pouring milk in your cereal
bowl before you put the cereal in these
are the kinds of things that make me
suspicious as far as I've seen there's
been no direct legal action taken
regarding any of these leagues but if
War Thunder fans continue to treat their
Forum like a dead drop then well it
could happen and that fake Reddit post
is built around a kernel of Truth like
most lies War Thunder players are
clearly a different breed and that
reputation is starting to spread War
Thunder was always fun back when I
played it and it sounds like they've
continued to develop the game and add
lots of cool stuff but folks trust me a
five percent increase to armor piercing
is not worth being brought up on
Espionage charges
so like anytime I wear this sweater it
has this like collar at the back and I
think you're supposed to like fold it
over but whatever whatever I have it I
pretend I'm like the dude from uttapao
that that that generally that Obi-Wan
goes to see and he's like looking for
General Grievous and he's like if you
have walias now is the time and then the
guy the power guy is like
you know and then he just goes he's like
just five anyways I don't know anytime I
put this Twitter on that's what I think
about it